foreign
Trudy in Georgia what's up Trudy
hey Dr Delaney thanks for taking our
call and our thanks to your wonderful
staff for their help
um
are they wonderful
they are wonderful okay I fully agree
with you I agree with you they're all
looking at me very mean very very mean
they are wonderful all right so true you
are in a pickle which is the most
Georgia thing you could say right now
except for go dogs all right so what's
why are you in a pickle
um I've got a 50 year old brother-in-law
he smokes four or five packs of
cigarette today drinks a lot he's a
hoarder he's got multiple addictions he
doesn't treat my husband well he's a
master manipulator
and he ended up in the hospital and we
got a call at 3am a couple of weeks ago
that they had to put him on a ventilator
and we need you to make these decisions
um we have no clue what he wanted but we
did the very best that we could and
while he was on the vent we found out
that he has a 16 year old daughter we
didn't know about his hoarding's out of
control there's a pornography addiction
his heat was cut off he's been telling
damaging lies about my husband and his
friends are calling him a habitual liar
the hospital got him healed up he's off
the vent we had him set up for Rehab but
he refused it and he checked himself out
of the hospital and we've been talking
about this my husband Rob and I and
we're ready to walk away but we know
that another call is going to come in
the middle of the night and so we had a
couple of questions for you and wondered
if you could help us know how do we
handle the next call that comes for the
next if can should we try to meet our
niece and then for me the guilt just
bites I was raised to take care of
family but enough is enough my father
mother-in-law called me two weeks before
he died both of my in-laws have passed
away and he called me two weeks before
he died and he asked me to take care as
a brother-in-law and it's just a hot
stinking mess and we were if any words
of wisdom you could share with us we'd
really appreciate it yeah I've got a lot
of opinions on this one hey let me uh
let me bring Rob in and
um I want to hear what he has to say
first I mean as well in addition to what
you just brought to us but
um yeah I've got some as you can imagine
I've got an opinion uh hang on one
second
hey Rob
hey Dr Maloney thank you for taking her
call you got it man what's up Chuck all
right so your your uh Trudy says you've
got you're all in it all right
yeah yeah we're in a
what's your sign and a hard place it's
been hard for a very long time so this
is most of my life so
well can I tell you this before you say
anything uh from what Trudy said it
sounds to me like this has been hard for
a long long time
and is a very simple
yet very difficult path forward
maybe super super difficult all right so
tell me what tell me what you're working
through my parents were very much
enablers of this they just kind of
looked past it oh that's how he is okay
and I swear if I hear anybody else say
that I might hit them but
um you know it just this behavior is
going on so long and been allowed so
long
that I just why why Rob let me ask you
why are you involved at all
your brother well yeah hold on hold on
your brother and your parents
buy their behavior told you
here's what we think of you
and you have continued to say yeah but
okay I'll figure out a way to make make
the relationship better I'll figure a
way to fix this
and not one time did brother or mom or
dad ever ask you to fix it they told you
here's the way we're choosing to live
our life
and for some reason you have tried
to stay connected to this madness why
yeah I don't The Only Thing Once me and
Judy were established as a couple uh was
we had kids and we wanted them to know
their grandparents their grandparents
were bad people okay that's fair and I
don't and just because
um they didn't have good boundaries or
they enabled I don't think their parents
are bad people but you can not be a bad
person you can be a fine person but I
can't spend time with you
you know what I mean some of my closest
friends I would say some of my closest
friends and friends I've had for all of
my life I don't want them to spend a ton
of time with my kids if any right I love
them but I've got some pretty
significant boundaries with him too
um okay so bring me forward your
brother's real real sick you stepped in
had to make some out of the blue hard
calls in the middle of the night
probably some life or death calls
um you guys set up a plan you thought
okay this is going to scare him straight
and he just walked right back into the
who he was and how he was oh and by the
way you have a niece that you didn't
know about
yeah yeah we we didn't even find that
out from him we found that out through
uh trying to track down his insurance
and a man asked me he said well can you
name his dependent I'm like well he
shouldn't have one uh he's like well we
have a 16 year old girl listed okay and
that's how I found out I had a niece and
my appearance had a granddaughter they
never knew anything about
um
which which the way you're saying that
and the way Trudy wait truly the way you
explain that y'all sounded surprised yet
nothing in this in your brother's
Behavior pattern would suggest this is a
surprise
uh yeah yeah I would I would say yeah I
don't get really surprised anymore it's
just
you don't need you these things come out
of nowhere of course that's right that's
right you know but I'm not surprised
that he lied about it yeah it's not a
surprise so how can I help you yeah true
to you there
I'm here yep so uh what what's what
comes next for y'all how can I help you
with what comes next
how do we handle the call that comes at
3am for the next of Ken
the next call that comes
uh
uh what do you mean
to the hot say the hospital calls us and
says hey your brother's here we had to
put him on a ventilator we need you to
make decisions you're his next of kin
okay do we we just go ahead and do the
same thing we just went through again
and try to make the very best decisions
we can
do we refer him back to the state
we don't we don't know what to do I
think that go ahead Rob
yeah part of that Dr Khan is he has
nothing in place he doesn't have a
uh what we used to call a living will he
doesn't have a will
he doesn't have no nobody knows
how to assist him in
paying his bills anything we you know
none of that stuff uh I I don't have
anything in place
and that tells me
either he's very very sick and you need
to get with an attorney
a very psychologically sick you get with
an attorney and have his civil rights
taken away and take take
um over custody of him essentially
or
if he is of sound mind
and he's just choosing to be the way he
is
then you have to hear his behavior as a
language and he is telling you I don't
want anything to do with you I never
have and I never will
and you and Trudy have to make your just
your choices Now set up your boundaries
now
and if you get a call in the middle of
the night and you say no regardless he's
my brother come come with me I'm gonna
be there for him
um
then y'all make that choice and when the
Call Comes at 3am then you help make the
decisions that you got to make at 3am
or you say I'm drawing a line
and I'm gonna tell him
either you get a living will or when I
get a call at 3am I'm gonna tell them
that we are estranged and I will I
refuse to make decisions for him I refer
him back to the state
oh yeah that's kind of that's kind of
where we were I can't tell you which one
of those to do but that's what we were
thinking too I I can't tell you what to
do what I can tell you is you need to
have that conversation and you and Trudy
Shake on it and you make it Ironclad
before you get that call
because when you get that call you're
gonna be really emotional it's gonna be
you know whatever whatever the
temperature happens to be outside and
suddenly you're going to find yourself
two weeks and ten thousand dollars
down a road that you don't want to be
down
yeah yeah
right and so uh
I I would not be able to sleep at night
it's just me
if I didn't come up with really firm
boundaries and I go make a direct have a
direct conversation with my brother I do
not care ones one second
what quote unquote other people are
saying about me
or what he's telling other people about
me could care less
I could care less what other people like
just saying he's a liar
they have no bearing on my life zero
none
I want to be able to look my brother in
the eye and say if you will have a will
I will help make decisions not if but
when the next call comes if you won't
make a will
and designate me as X Y and Z you will
be a ward of the state you get to choose
and I would want to have look him in I
don't need none of that I'm just telling
you
you see what I'm saying yeah yeah and
then when the Call Comes
you could you'll be able to weep and be
sad that your brother's passing away or
your brother's very very sick or
whatever but you'll also be able to know
I looked my brother in the eye and said
I will help if you will help and he said
no
either forcefully or through his
behavior he answered my question he said
no I don't want your help
yeah
you know what I mean yeah the problem
with having that conversation is not
what I've been through so many times I'm
so mad I don't even know if I can
have a five minute conversation you've
got civil conversations that's that's
that's that's up to you
um
I think you can I think you you can
decide to or decide not to
but I'm not I I'm I'm simply telling you
what I what I would do I can't I can't
put myself in your shoes right now
you've been dealing with this your whole
life
yeah
and uh so and as it refers to his his
new niece any conversations like it
would be inappropriate to just bombard a
16 year old with hey we're your family
um
that's that's what we've been discussing
today it's got to go through her whoever
her parent or Guardian is right now yeah
yeah and yeah yeah that's what I told
Trudy is that I do not want to turn this
girl's world upside down it sounds like
it already is upside down
um well I don't even know if she has
contact with him we still have it
okay reach that uh well actually I I
would I would communicate directly with
um
if you choose good on that road I would
identify her parent or Guardian
and communicate with them and let them
know hey we are
so and so's sane brother and
sister-in-law
and we found out we had a niece we
understand that our my brother my
brother-in-law is not a person of
character is a has a whole bunch of
challenges going on
um
we have our stuff together
and we now have identified her your
daughter as a new family member if and
when you are ready or she is ready and
wants to reach out fantastic if not we
fully understand right now
and that parent or Guardian may say we
don't want nothing to do with y'all get
out of our Lives we've had enough of
your family through your brother and
she's a minor so great and when she
turns 18
or she turns 21 and you want to reach
back out great now she's an adult and
she can make adult decisions
but right now don't bombard a child
with
you know contact saying oh by the way
that's that's a child can't carry that
weight that's why they got adults in
their lives so they got parents so work
through the parent or Guardian on that
one
um and so like I said earlier Rob and
Trudy this is it's it's heavy
and it's got a lot of weight to it
but the solution is very very simple
for a long long time your brother has
said I don't want you in my life
and yet you've said nope you're my
brother I'm gonna be here
and then when the call came in the
middle of the night you showed up
you're you're a family of outstanding
character and you go above and beyond
and then you go above and beyond that
and Trudy you can't help be held liable
for the dying wish of a dad who never
established boundaries never established
accountability never established
character or discipline in his son
you take care of him for me do you do
the job I never did
he doesn't get to lob that Grenade on
you as he passes away it's not for you
to carry
it's just not
you can love him you can love him
and that might look like
um power of attorney that might look
like you become his legal guardian
because he has lost his mind that might
be that you say we will support you uh
we'll we'll make those calls in the
middle of the night but only after you
do your part which is get a will get a
medical power of attorney get a fill in
the blank all the paperwork done
the path is pretty simple
Rob Trudy y'all go have a date together
cry together
be frustrated and angry together and
then walk away with a plan on here's how
we're gonna handle what comes next and
stick to the plan they all make together
I'm so sorry y'all are in this moment
but I'm glad you'll have each other to
lean on as you decide what to do next
let me know what you all decide and I'll
pass it along to our listeners